on ne dira pas qu'il s'agit du voyage de
la dernière chance d'une part puisque
c'est une formule qui a déjà été
employée par l'entourage dans tony
blinken à plusieurs reprises et ensuite
parce que l'enjeu est tel que washington
d'évidence cherchera à maintenir la
confrontation sur le seul terrain
diplomatique
aussi longtemps que possible même si
concrètement cette semaine les porte
parole de la maison blanche ont été
particulièrement pessimistes en
considérant que désormais une offensive
russe sur l'ukraine peut se déclencher
je cite à tout moment aucune prédiction
n'est réellement possible pas même une
évaluation du degré réel d'inquiétude de
joe biden une offensive russe en ukraine
aurait des conséquences difficiles à
mesurer sur les contreforts de l'europe
en termes de vies humaines bien sûr mais
il est également difficile d'évaluer à
quel escalade cela exposerait les pays
européens qui rappelons le sont
militairement en première ligne dans ce
dossier ce que jure cependant la
diplomatie américaine c'est que si un
seul char russe violent l'intégrité
territoriale ukrainienne des sanctions
économiques cataclysmique s'abattront
sur moscou